a kid's coding camp is suing critics for
speaking out against them this is a
coding camp named white hat jr
they're one of india's biggest startups
and they're in hot water
in response to mounting criticism
they're suing one man named pradeep
punya i hope i got that name right
for 2.7 million dollars in damages
okay they're accusing of defamation all
sorts of stuff which we're gonna get
into
but they say look it's not because the
guy criticized us it's because he
criticized us
unfairly according to them legitimate
honest fact-based criticism is
truly welcome well good guys so they
should have no problem with this video
right here because we're going to get to
the bottom of this we're going to
explain what's been going on
because i've been looking into this and
what i found is truly astonishing
and we're gonna take it from the
beginning okay so first of all let's
talk
code camps real quick they're giant
right now it's a gold rush
well rather coding is a gold rush and
the coding camps are the people selling
shovels
uh there's a lot of money in selling
shovels a lot of these coding camps
they're charging thousands of dollars to
teach coding and they basically hang an
apple or google job in front of their
applicants
and say well isn't it worth it to pay us
thousands of dollars to get this
education
now one of the things that should be
noted is there's a lot of free
coding educations out there like
freecodecamp.org and many others
but some people want to go down the paid
route because they think they're going
to get a better education
white hat jr is the latest of many
coding camps offering such a thing
but what makes them different is who
their target audience is rather than
targeting people in continuing education
or people who are in their 20s they're
targeting children
literally like six years old is where
they start
up to age 18 and they make some pretty
astounding claims
here's one of their ads right here to
give you an idea of the type of
advertising they do
they say space technology is the number
one future career for kids your kid can
learn to code a spaceship
in just 46 minutes start free coding and
a space tech trial
okay first of all it's not free it's
about 200 a month and obviously it's
ridiculous that someone can code a
spaceship in 46 minutes
right but they continue with this idea
basically telling you that actually the
fact that your kids so young
doesn't mean that they're hindered from
learning things like ai
and ml it actually means they may learn
it faster and you can see that in their
curriculum where they show you how much
your kids going to be learning and they
tell you things like
uh that your kid will get a game
developer certificate before they've
been through
eight classes of goading so you can have
your six-year-old going through seven
classes and all of a sudden
he's coding up candy crush in league of
legends and this has led many
people to criticize their overly
simplified and almost
dreamlike promises they're making to
parents that their kids going to be
the next bill gates and ads like this
reinforce the point
they're saying that you can make a 1.2
million
dollar salary at age 13. i mean
talk about selling parents a dream
you're saying hey
pay us 200 a month and your kid can
potentially be working at google it's
obviously google's campus
and be making a 1.2 million dollar
salary and this is where a lot of the
criticism is coming from
because not only did they suggest this
as a possibility
they actually said that one of their
students had achieved this
meet wolf gupta an example that white
hat jr was using
apparently he learned ai to get a 1.2
million dollar job and he's 13 at the
time when he did it
now here's where the cracks first start
to appear because later on
in different ads their story started to
change because over here
we have wolf gupta learning computers at
age
nine so he he actually learned it
quicker
in the new ad and he's making 150 crores
which is actually not just 1.2 million
dollars
it's actually 20 million dollars so he's
younger
and making way more money and here in
another ad the story changes
again where nine year old ryan
we changed it from wolf gupta learned
computers to earn
150 crores from google video while other
kids at his age were surfing youtube
videos
so here they are promoting a story that
appears to be false and there's no
disclaimer about hey this is a fictional
story it's aspirational whatever
nothing they're saying this is one of
our students this really happened
now this is where our first critic gets
involved pradeep punia
started to call them out for this
predatory behavior and he said look
you guys are false advertising to
parents you're not telling the truth
about this wolf gupta character
a lot of your stories are fake and he
starts publishing a bunch of videos
about it the problem with that
white hat jr doesn't like that they
don't want negative press
so what do they do rather than engaging
with the criticism
and saying look guys we messed up we
lied
instead they start copyright striking
the man
here's uh this guy he got five copyright
strikes in a row from white hat jr and
the company
that bought them out now they copyright
strike this guy so many times that he's
had to create
three different youtube channels where
he keeps uploading criticisms
of white hat jr now already this looks
really bad for white hat jr who claims
that they're
open to criticism right remember that at
the beginning of the video
keep giving us feedback to improve
legitimate honest fact-based criticism
is truly welcome so what's the problem
well they claim that our critic here
is lying and making illegal breaches
that damage real lives now what are they
talking about
well to find out let's go to the lawsuit
first thing to know about this lawsuit
it's 820 pages long
the second thing you should know about
it is in the lawsuit they
admit that a lot of the criticism is
true
this wolf gupta character doesn't exist
it was
a lie according to white hat jr
themselves their own lawsuit
it was an imaginary child who the
plaintiffs christened wolf
gupta so it's imaginary it didn't happen
but nowhere in that thing did it say it
they were saying hey we got the student
he made millions of dollars with our
classes oh but actually he doesn't exist
didn't you guys know he's imaginary
didn't you didn't you know that
no nobody knew it so they admit in the
lawsuit that that is true
but then call out our guy for saying
that plaintiff one had
murdered wolf gupta when they withdrew
their advertisements they say
the defendant's posts quickly turned
sinister subsequent to the withdrawal of
the advertisement to this i have to say
obviously this is a joke when you say oh
yeah they murdered wolfe gupta that's
obviously a joke that the guy's making
nobody's gonna construe that as
literally they killed a kid
so that's a super bad faith
interpretation obviously he's just being
tongue-in-cheek with the fact that
suddenly this mysterious kid who's your
poster child of success
just mysteriously vanishes the saying
they murdered him it's a joke but then
the other giant allegation here is that
the defendant
hacked into their slack communications
things they do you see that
even hacked into plaintiff number two's
internal business communications
platform
and this is actually where things become
pretty complicated and things get kind
of muddy
because it's true that pretty punia
published to his
twitter and his youtube channel multiple
slack communications from this company
but what's unclear is how he got them
some people have said that they
accidentally left their slack public
some people have said that he obtained a
ceo password
and some people have said it was a
whistleblower that released
this to the public it's not clear how he
got it
in my opinion obviously hacking isn't
okay but if it's a whistleblower that
came to him
and released these images to him i think
that's a different thing altogether to
release those into the public if they're
of
public interest and after reading them i
definitely
think they are i'm not saying that any
ins justify the means here of how you
get them
but now that they're out in the public
it's interesting that the fact that
they're calling them out for hacking
their platform and releasing them into
the public domain
they're almost confirming that these
leaks are
indeed real and valid because obviously
if they were fake they would say
oh he photoshopped these false things
instead their argument is
he took confidential communications and
published them which again i'm not
defending it because we don't know how
he got those but what these slack
communications
reveal now that they're in the public
it's pretty damning
i'm gonna have to censor out a lot here
just fyi so if you see it blurred it's
because i'm trying to protect
you know employee information here but
basically we see a series of screenshots
of employees seeming to be reporting uh
criticisms from various twitter accounts
from all sorts of things contradicting
their idea that they're open to
criticism and it's only you know bad
faith criticism that they don't like
because
they're just reporting everything they
even report a depressed employee who
says
exploitation of teachers and employees
at work in white hat jr 15 hours working
every day seven days a week
team leader warned to terminate if
raised voice feels frustrated depressed
the internal slack says can we report
the tweet also
another one is talking about a negative
video and they say don't reply just get
the video down
so they don't want to engage with
criticism they're not interested in that
they just want to censor voices but
worst of all i think is
this communication which came from their
ceo
okay somebody raised a concern and they
posted to a chat
where a parent or some kind of like
would-be client is asking about an
ad that was published where a 13 year
old is becoming the ceo of a face
detecting app
and they're saying one of my students is
interested in to see the app made by
that student
any ideas how to check that so they're
saying where's this app that you claim
was made by one of your students
and the ceo of white hat jr is saying
need to create that app now
which is so disgusting i mean really
internalize that
they've advertised this thing they've
created this whole narrative that this
was done by a kid it can be done by your
kid
you should pay us 200 a month because
you know this is
reasonable expectations or at least this
is what can be expected
and this guy's saying that when somebody
asks for proof he seems to be implying
at once that it doesn't exist
and that if it was to exist it'd have to
be coded by a professional engineer
to which one of their employees responds
that a person can create and send it as
promised and they ask do you want me to
another employee responds i can create
the app i cannot get a 13 year old to
create
the company around it at least not now
which
of course not and so they're saying
internally that they
know they can't get a 13 year old to do
this and the ceo responds
that we will this is so bad
and demonstrates a pattern of behavior
so
wolf gupta was not the only one that
they did this with it wasn't just one
offhand thing multiple examples they use
about
oh these kids are coding these crazy
apps and your kids can
too they are fabricating these
narratives so it's this weird thing
right because in the lawsuit
the slack channel like the slack channel
discussion is kind of a poison chalice
for white hat junior
because on the one hand they have a
point punia should not have released
private communications
you know it depends how he got them if
he got them through a whistleblower
then he didn't hack them i mean that's
just not true it just depends
but the fact that they admit that these
slack communications exist and they seem
to be
verifying that they are real is an even
worse
look for the company than anything that
they've admitted publicly so that's
where the story is now
um it's not believable that white hat jr
is only going after people
who are you know being unfair to them
they are silencing
all criticism that comes their way it's
very clear from the messages that
they're reporting anything and
everything that can be construed as
criticism at all
you can be sure that they'll report this
video they'll report any video that
talks about them
and frankly that's the part that bothers
me the most because in order to root out
corruption scams to tell the frauds
from the people who are honest you have
to have that criticism you have to have
the open exchange even when it's sort of
intense and it can be loaded with some
pretty heavy language
you have to have it you have to have it
for the people who are buying into this
stuff
this is a multi-multi-multi-million
dollar company
and it needs to be exposed to criticism
to see if it holds up
and right now they're not doing that my
hope is as always that the truth comes
out
thanks for watching and we may do a
follow-up on this as more information
comes out
see you next time and don't forget to
smash like
and subscribe thank you up